una denuncia de amenaza que evoca
fantasmas del pasado el candidato de
izquierda a la presidencia a gustavo
petro suspendió su gira en el centro de
colombia por razones de seguridad su
equipo habría recibido información de
planes para atentar contra su vida
lamentable que tenga que suspender la
gira del eje cafetero el paso de los
sectores de la corrupción apagar bandas
de sicarios para mi eliminación física
muestra la desesperación política a la
que han llegado
gustavo petro pensaba viajar el 3 y el 4
de mayo al eje cafetero en el centro del
país allí opera una organización
criminal conocida como la cordillera que
estaría detrás de la amenaza y está
señalada de haber acabado con la vida
del estudiante lucas biglia en pereira
durante el paro nacional de 2021 una
conmoción ya conocida para colombia pues
el país tiene un historial de
magnicidios contra candidatos
presidenciales el 9 de abril de 1948
jorge eliécer gaitán fue asesinado en el
centro de bogotá dando lugar a una
cruenta guerra entre liberales y
conservadores en 1989 el liberal luis
carlos galán fue asesinado cuando era
favorito para ganar la contienda de 1990
antes de esas elecciones también
murieron el líder de la desmovilizada
guerrilla del m-19 a la que perteneció a
gustavo petro carlos pizarro y el
izquierdista bernardo jaramillo ossa de
la unión patriótica organización contra
la que la jurisdicción especial para la
paz considera que hubo un genocidio
temores de tiempos pasados cuando según
la última encuesta de invamer gustavo
petro la ventaja en alrededor de 17
puntos al candidato de la derecha
federico gutiérrez potencia mundial